es sind harte maßnahmen die wir
verabschiedet haben es sind belastende
maßnahmen es sind maßnahmen für das
gesamte land
die bundeskanzlerin vor einer guten
stunde bund und länder einigen sich auf
einschneidende neue regeln um die korona
zahlen in den griff zu bekommen
es gibt deutlich strengere kontakt
beschränkungen vier wochen lang muss
vieles dicht machen
denn november wird ein schwieriger monat
für deutschland die nachrichten des
tages heute mit christian sievers so
nahm den an diesem mittwoch sport in der
sendung nachher mit kristin otto
beschränkungen bei uns genannt
deutschland geht wieder in einen
teilweisen lockdown ab 2 november müssen
alle restaurants und bars schließen auch
alle freizeiteinrichtungen und
sportanlagen theater kinos konzerthäuser
bis ende november
ziel der neuen regeln die bund und
länder beschlossen haben die rasant
steigenden infektionszahlen in den griff
bekommen julia schröter hat die details
die wichtigste maßnahme in der nächsten
zeit abstand halten
die bürger sind angehalten ihre kontakte
auf ein absolut nötiges minimum zu
beschränken
wie schon im frühjahr wird der
aufenthalt in der öffentlichkeit nur mit
angehörigen des eigenen und eines
weiteren hausstands gestattet maximal
zehn personen auf private reisen soll
verzichtet werden
gleiches gilt für besucher auch von
verwandten übernachtungen in hotels zu
touristischen zwecken werden verboten
auch die freizeitmöglichkeiten werden
eingeschränkt konzerthäuser theater und
kinos müssen zu machen
gleiches gilt für sportvereine und
fitnessstudios dort wird es kein
training geben
gastronomiebetriebe wie bars kneipen und
restaurants müssen ebenfalls schließen
erlaubt bleibt aber dass speisen
abgeholt oder geliefert werden
der hand die bleibt mit strengen hygiene
und abstandsregeln weiter geöffnet
anders als bei der ersten welle und auch
schulen und kitas bleiben diesmal offen
all das gilt ab anfang kommender woche
november nochmal einen zitat nationalen
kraftakt also fordert die
bundeskanzlerin jetzt von den deutschen
auch für die politischen entscheider sei
das ein schwerer tag andreas ruppert
fasst die diskussion heute in berlin
zusammen
video gipfel im kanzleramt zur corona
bekämpfung sind längst zur routine
geworden keine routine dagegen die frage
welches mittel welches rezept hilft die
pandemie einzige auch heute wieder
viereinhalb stunden beratungen danach
präsentieren bundesregierung und länder
ein maßnahmenpaket mit harten
entscheidungen
deshalb ist das heute ein schwerer tag
auch für politische entscheidungsträger
ich will das ausdrücklich sagen weil wir
wissen dass wir den menschen zumuten
aber wir müssen den weg finden wie wir
sozusagen gesundheit sicherstellen
können in eine nationale
gesundheitsfrage nicht hinein geraten
einen totalen lockdown will die
regierung vermeiden will schulen kitas
und den großteil der deutschen
wirtschaft am laufen halten
allerdings sollen kontakte auf einen
absoluten nötige minimum reduziert
werden
letztlich ist das das entscheidende
motto kontakte reduzieren und deckt wir
reduzieren kontakte reduzieren wenn wir
jetzt zu gucken werden wir vielen
menschen nicht helfen können das muss
jedem einfach bewusst sein
deshalb müssen die gastronomie und
freizeiteinrichtungen weitgehend wieder
dichtmachen die regierung will die
betroffenen allerdings entschädigen wie
werden die von den temporären
schliessungen erfassten unternehmen
unternehmen betriebe selbst wenn vereine
und einrichtungen mit einer
ausserordentlichen wirtschaftshilfe
unterstützen die der erstattungsbetrag
beträgt bis zu 75 prozent für
unternehmen mit bis zu 50 mitarbeitern
amateur sportveranstaltungen werden
untersagt kinos konzerthäuser und messen
geschlossen
die entscheidungen sind einvernehmlich
gefallen auch jene ministerpräsidenten
die bedenken hatten stimmten zu wenn wir
jetzt schaffen die infektionsraten
niedrig zu halten
und den anstieg und die dynamik zu
brechen
dann sind wir in der lage mit dem virus
klarzukommen
zuviel reglementierung schimpft die fdp
etliche der angedachten maßnahmen seien
schlichtweg verfassungswidrig
die bundeskanzlei es dafür nicht
zuständig sondern nur die länder sind
dafür zuständig diese
bekämpfungsmaßnahmen vorzunehmen und sie
müssen sich orientieren an den
grundlagen unserer verfassung es muss
erforderlich und verhältnismäßig sein
die linke im bundestag fühlt sich bei
den entscheidungen nicht einbezogen die
entscheidung muss raus aus dem
bundeskanzleramt und rein in die
parlamente corona gipfel nummer 9 hat
getagt und drastische einschränkungen
beschlossen morgen will angela merkel
diese dem parlament im bundestag
erläutern und dann besonders sprechen
mit sharp energy in berlin
guten abend bislang war da wenig an
gemeinsamer linie von allen ländern mit
dem bund zu sehen hat sich das mit dem
heutigen tag geändert
ja da scheinen wir heute tatsächlich
einen einschnitt auch auf dieser ebene
zu sehen
man kann tatsächlich sagen so viel
einigkeit gab es schon lange nicht mehr
selbst thüringen das sich ja vorher
extrem kritisch gezeigt hat und gesagt
hat bundesweiten regelungen die einen
lock down a kommt wolle man nicht
zustimmen sagt jetzt ja zu diesem
beschluss fügt aber hinzu dass das land
einen beschluss von bundestag und
bundesrat fordert in dem der akuten
national eine akute nationale
gesundheitslage ausgerufen wird die die
maßnahmen die heute beschlossen wurden
rechtfertigen dass es extra in einem
zusatzprotokoll an diesen beschluss dran
gehängt worden aber alles in allem kann
man sagen es gab hier eine erstaunliche
einigkeit heute alle sind sich einig
dass sie diese notbremse jetzt treten
wollen
die juristische seite reden wir nachher
in der sendung noch einmal detaillierter
jetzt werden ja branchen schwer leiden
unter den neuen regeln gerade auch die
die sich bereits enorm umgestellt hatten
und konzepte umgesetzt hatten
der staat berlin entgegen kommen wir
haben es gerade kurz gehört was wird
denn das für ein neues
milliardenprogramm werden ja in der tat
wollen bund und länder die ganze sache
noch einmal flankieren der bund will bis
zu zehn milliarden
euro in die hand nehmen um die folgen
abzupuffern und diesmal soll tatsächlich
auch niemand vergessen werden die hilfen
sollen also sowohl unternehmen als auch
kultureinrichtungen wie zum beispiel
theater aber auch kleinstunternehmen und
solo selbstständigen zugute kommen
finanzminister scholz und
wirtschaftsminister altmaier sollen in
den kommenden tagen noch in dieser woche
vorstellen
wie das genau im detail aussehen soll
das ist nochmal eine menge geld die der
bund hier zusätzlich zu den schon
ausgegebenen hilfen in die hand nimmt
noch einmal steuergelder die hier in die
hand genommen werden um eben diese vier
wochen für die das ganze jetzt erst
einmal gilt irgendwie aufzufangen und
die härten aus diesem programm
herauszunehmen und der herzlichen dank
hintergrund des ganzen sind die rasant
steigenden infektionszahlen täglich neue
problematische rekorde
die vom robert-koch-institut verkündet
werden auch heute wieder ein neuer
höchststand bei den neuinfektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden wurden 14 1964
neue fälle registriert und eine
steigerung gibt es auch bei den
neuinfektionen im sieben tage schnitt
der liegt heute bei 11.000 120 nach zehn
1460 gestern die neuen regeln werden die
wieder besonders hart treffen die
ohnehin schon seit beginn der pandemie
extrem leiden es gibt heute proteste der
betreiber von kinos und gaststätten auch
viele künstler fürchten um ihre existenz
campino der sänger der band tote hosen
sagt offensichtlich hat die politik den
sommer verschlafen und dann melden sich
heute auch wissenschaftler und ärzte zu
wort die die richtung der neuen
maßnahmen ganz grundsätzlich kritisieren
christoph festival mit mehr dazu corona
routine in der fußgängerzone
so sieht's aus hierzulande am tag der
neuen beschränkungen für alle muss sein
antwortet in frankfurt am main fast
jeder
ich finde das jetzt als notfallmaßnahme
angebracht und in ordnung bei den
steigenden
das ist ja in unser aller interesse dass
das nicht so weiter geht ja ich finde es
traurig dass es notwendig wurde also es
hätte das sicherlich auch mit etwas
selbstdisziplin anders laufen können
strenge maßnahmen kann man gut finden
wenn es einen finanziell nicht trifft
aber was wenn doch augsburg auch hier
überdurchschnittlich viel corona und
mittendrin das hotel drei [ __ ] gerade
lief es wieder einigermaßen jetzt erneut
weitgehend runterfahren
diese wohl kurzarbeit für die meisten
gleichzeitig ist der manager positiv
überrascht dass der staat den jetzt
absehbaren november verlust abfedern
will 75 prozent ist auf jeden fall etwas
aus einem weiterhilft darf nicht
vergessen das ist immerhin oktober bis
dezember das sind die wichtigsten monate
im jahr
sämtliche konferenzen mit wohl noch mehr
stehen musiker kleinkünstler oder
bühnentechniker mit dem rücken zur wand
um fünf nach zwölf starteten sie also
ihre demo heute in berlin
finanziell oft einzelkämpfer
zusammengenommen aber mehr als eine
million betroffene
nichts falsch gemacht trotzdem am
abgrund das kann nicht sein sagen andere
bekannte gesichter und solidarisieren
sich campino von den toten hosen etwa
haben diese leute millionen von steuern
bezahlt aus überzeugung und im vertrauen
darauf dass das system sinnvoll und
gerecht ist und ihnen im gegenzug zur
seite springt und hilft wenn sie
unverschuldet in not geraten und dann
sagt er noch für diese betroffenen gehe
es nicht darum weihnachten zu retten
sondern ein ganzes jahr länger denken
weiter planen das fordern heute auch
namhafte mediziner und biologen ein
kurzzeitiger ein vierwöchiger lockdown
wird unter großen großen nebenwirkungen
dazu führen dass die zahl nach und nach
unten gehen und dann sind wir wieder in
der gleichen situation dass uns die
frage stellen was ist eigentlich unsere
langfristige strategie die so steht's im
positionspapier der ärzte könnte auch
beinhalten dass man etwa kneipen sehr
wohl offen hält aber bei den auflagen
ganz genau hinguckt denn es sei besser
wenn menschen sich in öffentlichen
räumen mit hygiene konzepten unter
optimalen bedingungen treffen als dass
sich die soziale begegnungen in
vergleichsweise weniger sichere private
räume verlagern
die jetzt beschlossenen einschränkungen
heißen andere ärzte übrigens
ausdrücklich gut so wird wohl
weitergehen müssen deutschland tastet
sich durch eine so noch nie dagewesene
prüfung jetzt haben wir erlebt dass die
gerichte zunehmend nicht mehr
einverstanden sind mit dem was die
politik davor gibt stichwort
beherbergungs verbot felix zimmermann
ist bei uns aus unserer zdf rechts
redaktion hallo felix kann man dann
annehmen dass auch diese neuen heute
verkündeten regeln wieder sehr schnell
vor gericht landen
und das lässt sich natürlich sicher
nichts sagen aber hat der vergangenheit
jetzt erlebt durchwinken das machen die
gerichte nicht mehr
allerdings sind ja nun wirklich die
infektionszahlen dramatisch gestiegen
sodass das zentrale argument heute jetzt
handeln ansonsten wird es später noch
schlimmer und wird noch grundrechts
intensivere einschränkungen geben
sicherlich so manches verwaltungsgericht
überzeugen könnte außerdem sind die
maßnahmen zeitlich befristet
november und es werden offensichtlich
umfangreiche entschädigung geben für
viele geschäftsbetriebe andererseits
sind die maßnahme natürlich sehr
pauschal gegen bundesweit selbst dort wo
die krone in sident von 50 gar nicht
überschritten wird
also ist ein oder andere
verwaltungsgericht könnte die ein oder
andere kroner maßnahme wieder kippen
flächendeckende entscheidungen diese
richtung nämlich nicht an an welchem
punkt ist es denn aus juristischer sicht
dringend geboten dass solche
einschneidenden maßnahme dann auch
tatsächlich vom parlament beschlossen
werden und nicht einfach von regierungen
wie aktuell ja herr söder hat es heute
in der pressekonferenz selbst gesagt die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sei ja
eigentlich gar nicht demokratisch
legitimiert damit spricht er an dass in
der demokratie die wesentlichen
regelungen vom parlament der
volksvertretung kommen müssen und
natürlich sind solche grundrechts
intensiven regelung wie corona maßnahmen
ganz sicherlich wesentlich
andererseits sind solche notlagen wo man
eben auch schnell handeln muss eben die
sogenannte stunde der exekutive
doch die stunde die ist nun längst
abgelaufen acht monate
diese maßnahmen so dass die stimmen
jetzt wirklich laut werden die
parlamente müssen sich beteiligen die
macht dazu hätten sie auch darüber
werden sicherlich die gerichte bald man
entscheiden müssen felix vielen dank für
diese information aus juristischer sicht
tag der entscheidung schärfere maßnahmen
gegen korona so heißt das zdf spezial
zur lage in deutschland gleich nach
dieser sendung den überblick über alles
wichtige im kampf gegen die virus krise
auch jederzeit in einem live blog in der
zdf- heute- app aber wir bleiben noch im
moment beim thema schauen auf die
situation in anderen ländern für
frankreich könnte präsident manual makro
in einer knappen stunde ebenfalls
weitreichende einschränkungen verkünden
viele ärzte hatten dafür plädiert weil
bereits mehr als die hälfte der
intensivbetten mit corona patienten
belegt ist
die meisten neuinfizierten im verhältnis
zur einwohnerzahl in europa hat
tschechien
hier gilt jetzt eine ausgangssperre
zwischen 21 und 5 uhr morgens ganz
anderes bild in melbourne australien
dort feiern sie das ende des jüngsten
lockdown allerdings hat der in melbourne
immerhin fast vier monate lang gedauert
unser nächstes thema in der sendung noch
sechs tage dann ist präsidentenwahl in
den usa bereits jetzt haben mehr als 71
millionen amerikaner ihre stimme
abgegeben per brief oder persönlich das
ist bereits jetzt mehr als die hälfte
der stimmen die beim letzten mal vor
vier jahren insgesamt abgegeben wurden
die umfragen sehen weiterhin gut aus für
den demokraten joe biden amtsinhaber
donald trump zeigt sich trotzdem
optimistisch island ski ausflug zur oz
statt peitsche der wahlzettel in der
hand die aktion einer gruppe cowboys
unweit von los angeles ihr ziel
aufmerksamkeit erzeugen um möglichst
viele zum umgang zu bewegen
das ist unser privileg die stimmabgabe
landauf landab das gleiche bild noch nie
haben so viele amerikaner vor dem
offiziellen wahltag abgestimmt mehr als
70 millionen wegen der pandemie haben in
den meisten bundesstaaten wahllokale
bereits wochen im voraus ihre tore
geöffnet
du musst abstimmen das ist das einzige
recht dass uns die reichen und mächtigen
nicht weggenommen haben
ich möchte dass wir als land besser
werden es gibt viele ungerechtigkeiten
und dinge die behoben werden müssen
der kampf ums weiße haus das thema in
den us-medien trump oder beiden wer
gewinnt wie viele von den notwendigen
wahlmännern und -frauen um die magische
zahl von 270 stimmen zu erreichen
umfragen prognosen hochrechnungen im
moment liegen die demokraten vorne
viele haben schon ihre stimme abgegeben
doch manche experten warnen vor falschen
erwartungen trailer kam vor vier jahren
am wahltag in großer zahl heraus und
überwanden den vorteil den demokraten
bei der frühen abstimmung hatten
rekordzahlen lange schlangen eine
geduldsprobe und trotzdem gute laune
warum nicht das nützliche mit dem
schönen verbinden auch das ist amerika
zurück nach deutschland der gesetzliche
mindestlohn steigt ab dem neuen jahr von
9 eur 35 auf 9 euro 50 in drei weiteren
schritten wird er zum ersten juli 2022
auf 10 eur 45 angehoben
das beschloss das bundeskabinett in
berlin spd arbeitsminister hubertus heil
sagte die von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften vorgeschlagene anpassung
berücksichtige auch die wirtschaftlichen
unsicherheiten der korona pandemie sechs
castor-behälter mit hochradioaktivem
atommüll aus der britischen
wiederaufbereitungsanlage sellafield
sind in einem spezialschiff auf dem weg
nach deutschland
atomkraftgegner und umweltschützer gehen
davon aus dass die behälter über den
niedersächsischen hafen nordenham ins
land kommen
die fracht wird dann per bahn ins
hessische zwischenlager biblis gebracht
europäische kulturhauptstadt das diesen
titel in fünf jahren neben einer
slowenischen auch eine deutsche stadt
tragen wird war klar
seit heute wissen wir welche es wird
chemnitz
dafür hat sich eine internationale jury
entschieden die sächsische stadt setzte
sich gegen hannover hildesheim nürnberg
und magdeburg durch kontinents zeigt
womit chemnitz überzeugen konnte und wie
die entscheidung in der stadt ankommt
jubel tränen emotion in chemnitz wird
kulturhauptstadt 2025 der underdog aus
dem osten plötzlich gewinner
das herz wurde immer lauter vor klopfen
und eigentlich könnte ich die ganze welt
umarmen wird sind total stolz total
glücklich
chemnitz und die region hat es auch
wirklich verdient chemnitz die alte
industriestadt in sachsen will zeigen
dass es bunter ist als die graue ost
modernes erwarten lässt
kunstprojekte im öffentlichen raum
ausstellungen konzerte sollen die
besucher anlocken
er wird so viel geschafft und gemacht
und mit sehr viel fleiß und viel erfolg
und diese stimmung diese energie die in
der stadt entstanden ist die konnten wir
auch in das bewerbungsbuch und am ende
auch in die präsentation einbringen und
ich bin einfach glücklich dass die jury
das überzeugt chemnitz kämpft gegen sein
schlechtes image gegen rechtsextremismus
präsentiert sich kreativ bunt und
weltoffen und das soll jeder in europa
sehen wenn wir das gut nutzen dann haben
wir für 2025 einfach eine wahnsinns gute
grundlage um
auch gäste aus ganz europa begrüßen zu
dürfen und dass man das hier wirklich
alles was ganz tolles kennenlernt
chemnitz rechnet mit zwei millionen
gästen im jahr 2025 ein
millionenschweres konjunkturprogramm für
eine region in der die landschaften
nicht überall blühen
glückwunsch nach chemnitz
und jetzt der sport auch wieder ganz neu
im schatten von corona allerdings
geister stehen die spiele und stillstand
sind die schlagwörter auch den sport hat
es also wieder hart getroffen
im november sind keine zuschauer im
deutschen profisport erlaubt der amateur
und freizeitsport wird in dieser zeit
weitestgehend untersagt das führt
natürlich existenznöte bei vereinen die
weitaus mehr auf zuschauereinnahmen
angewiesen sind als der fußball
einzig im riesigen berliner
olympiastadion hofft die hertha am
wochenende noch auf 500 zuschauer
dies ist nach vorgabe des senats möglich
ansonsten wird es schon am wochenende
komplett leere stadien der bundesliga
geben andere mannschaftssportarten
trifft es härter als den fußball
eishockey volleyball basketball handball
sie sind deutlich stärker abhängig von
zuschauern mindestens einen monat ohne
einnahmen aus diesem bereich auszukommen
das brächte viele in extreme finanzielle
not ihr leben nicht von den entgelten
ihres bereich der fußball macht sondern
wir leben von den zuschauern und von
sponsoren partner beide der einnahmen
daten sind schwer gebeutelt momentan
derart höheren freizeit sport in
vereinen ist noch härter betroffen nicht
nur keine zuschauer sondern der
komplette spielbetrieb muss im november
ruhen und kurzfristig vor leeren rängen
gestern abend auch das zweite
champions-league-spiel von borussia
mönchengladbach trotz vielversprechender
leistungen reicht das gegen real madrid
durch die aufholjagd der königlichen mit
späten ausgleich nur zu einem 2 2
ein unentschieden das sich wie eine
niederlage anfühlte nach einem fast
perfekten spiel der gladbacher bis zur
minute mit einem türrahmen als
geschickte im fond länder sehenswerter
spielzüge
sein 1 0 vor der pause das 2 0 nach
einer stunde real am rande der
niederlage ging voll ins risiko
dann tut das nicht mehr so aktiv weg
verteidigen kannst dann ist das in der
summe natürlich extrem bitter
zwei gegentore in den letzten minuten
erst benzema und dann nach gleichem
muster in der nachspielzeit casimiro wie
in mailand ein später ausgleich gladbach
ungeschlagen sieglos ganz wie man es
betrachtet die bayern dagegen zuvor
erfolgreich in moskau zu viel da können
uns jetzt alle gemeinsam noch die zahlen
vom mittwoch lotto anschauen
und die lauten 27 12 23 36 43 superzahl
4 weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf.de
im zdf text auf seite 55 7 und das
wetter wird im süden nassen mit
dauerregen im norden ist auch mal mit
sonne zu rechnen alles weitere gleich
von gunther tiersch von uns was für den
moment danke für ihr großes interesse
vielmehr zum thema neue drastische
coroner regeln in deutschland
nachher im heute journal mit bettina
schausten viertel vor zehn und natürlich
jetzt gleich nach uns im zdf spezial bis
morgen und in allen wo immer das geht
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
mit der liebe zuschauer mit dem nächsten
regen wurde es morgen vorübergehend
etwas kühler bei uns unser wetter kommt
ja aus westen vom atlantik und immer
wieder ziehen regengebiete über uns
hinweg dass heute nacht und morgen und
das nächste baut sich über
großbritannien auf erreicht uns dann
morgen abend dahinter kommt es dann
kommt die milde luft fürs wochenende ja
heute nacht erst mal dagegen aus westen
ja auch morgen früh berlin und die oder
erreicht das wird windiger dazu und
morgen früh sind es sieben bis zwölf im
südöstlichen bayern auch vier grad und
tagsüber ist es etwas kühler als heute
meist sind es so zwischen 9 und 14 grad
in norddeutschland haben wir durchaus
chancen auf sonnenschein vor allem am
nachmittag werden die sonnigen lücken
etwas größer
sonst gibt es immer wieder schauer an
den küsten und es wird dieser starke
westwind den habe auch in süddeutschland
aber nur am vormittag nachmittags lässt
der wind nach dafür gibt es dauerregen
südlich des mains der erst am nachmittag
etwas schwächer von westen wird bevor am
abend dann neuer regen den rhein
erreicht und dieser regen zieht am
freitag dann noch über den norden und
osten deutschlands zum wochenende wird
es sonniger allerdings auch wärmer und
stürmisch an der nordsee mit neuem regen
ich wünschen einen schönen abend und
mach s gut